para esta reacción de ti el saldo he
agregado un grupo donador de electrones
al lleno aquí tenemos al lleno y
observen que tiene un grupo med occ si
unido a este carbón eso significa que
tenemos dos posibles productos para esta
reacción de ti el saldo podemos formar
este producto o este pero cuál será el
producto favorecido bueno para
descubrirlo necesitamos dibujar las
estructuras de resonancia del lleno y el
día no filo empecemos con el bien
podemos tomar este par de electrones
libres en el oxígeno y moverlos hacia
acá empujando estos electrones a este
carbono dibujemos la estructura de
resonancia ahora el oxígeno está unido
con un doble enlace a este carbono y
este carbono tiene
par de electrones libres dibujemos el
resto de la molécula el oxígeno tiene un
par de electrones libres lo que le da
una carga formal positiva y este carbono
tiene una carga formal negativa
voy a resaltarlo este carbono tiene una
carga formal negativa y no olvidemos
poner los corchetes de resonancia ahora
vamos con el día en off y sabemos que el
oxígeno es más electro negativo así que
la densidad de electrónica fluye hacia
el oxígeno podemos mover este par de
electrones hacia acá empujando a estos
electrones al oxígeno dibujemos la
estructura de resonancia aquí tenemos un
doble enlace y el oxígeno ahora tiene
tres pares de electrones libres lo que
le da una carga formal negativa pongamos
los corchetes
observen que le quitamos un enlace a
este carbono así que este carbono tiene
una carga forma al positivo entonces el
lleno tiene un carbono rico en
electrones y el 10 nov y lo tiene un
carbono pobre en electrones y recordemos
que las cargas opuestas se atraen así
que simplemente podemos alinear estos
dos carbonos y eso nos permite predecir
la región química para esta reacción la
reacción de ty el saler
no es una reacción iónica más bien
esper y cíclica pero este truco nos
ayuda a predecir el producto primero re
dibujemos el yen o filo aquí tenemos un
doble enlace y después tenemos el grupo
carbón y lo sabemos que este carbono es
pobre en electrones es parcialmente
positivo y necesitamos alinearlo con el
carbono rico en electrones
del 10 este carbono es rico en
electrones eso significa que el grupo
med occ si está unido a este carbón así
ya podemos ver la región química para
esta reacción de di el saldo recuerden
que la reacción de ti el saler consiste
en el movimiento concertado de 6
electrones pib así que estos electrones
se mueven hacia acá para formar un
enlace entre estos dos carbonos al mismo
tiempo que estos electrones se mueven
hacia acá para formar otro enlace y
estos electrones se mueven hacia abajo
hemos formado nuestro ciclo externo
y después en este carbono tenemos al
grupo med occ sí y en este carbono
tenemos una sector
resaltemos los electrones estos
electrones en rojo formaron este enlace
estos electrones en azul formaron este
enlace y los electrones en rosa formaron
este entonces este producto es más
favorecido que éste